hallo leute ihr seid auf jeden Fall
richtig aber Christoph kann gerade nicht
und deswegen mache ich das jetzt mal
schnell selbst was ein bisschen komisch
ist ich gehe mal davon aus dass
allerhöchstens die Mädels gerade was mit
mir anfangen können die Jungs wissen
überhaupt nicht was los ist also ich bin
darum ich habe ein Beauty Mode und
Lifestyle Kanal auf Youtube und ihr
könnt es euch denken ich darf zu
klicksom ins Interview und zu diesem
Zweck würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn
ihr mir eure Fragen stellt ihr würdet
Christ damit bestimmt auch helfen das
muss nicht alles zum Thema Beauty sein
das kann gerne auch tiefsinnig unsinnig
und leichtsinnig sein postet eure Frage
als Videoantwort unter dieses Video
vielleicht bekommen wir ein bisschen was
zusammen ich weiß ich kann nicht rappen
ich bin nicht lustig aber ja gibt mir
eine Chance übrigens findet das
Interview live auf der Bühne beim
Medienforum in Köln am 20.06 statt und
dazu findet ihr weitere Information in
der Infobox und allgemein wä es auch mal
gut wenn ihr in die Infobox klickt und
ansonsten war das von mir bis dann
bleibt
dran